-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden spoke today
at the White House
Summit for Democracy.
The speech went so well, we're
even thinking about trying it.
[ Laughter ]
House Speaker Kevin McCarthy
sent President Biden
a letter yesterday morning
and asked him to pick a date
to continue negotiations
over raising the debt ceiling
because nothing conveys
the desire
to get something done quickly
like sending a letter.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
House Speaker Kevin McCarthy
sent President Biden
in a letter yesterday
and outlined Republican demands
for raising the debt ceiling
and, for the greater good,
Hillary's agreed to it.
[ Laughter ]
Not real. Don't worry.
President Biden
told reporters yesterday
that he has already used
the full extent
of his executive authority
to ban assault weapons
and added that Congress
"has to act."
"Well, I did win
the Oscar for 'Lincoln,'"
said George Santos.
[ Laughter ]
A bipartisan group of
congressmen announced this week
that they will reintroduce
the Protection from
Abusive Passengers Act,
which would ban
airline passengers
who've been fined or convicted
of physical violence on flights
and prison time for anyone who
takes off their shoes and socks.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
former First Lady Melania Trump
likes living at Mar-a-Lago
because she's surrounded
by people
who do not say bad things
about former President Trump.
Okay, but word of advice,
don't go in the kitchen.
[ Laughter ]
Pepsi yesterday unveiled its new
logo design for North America.
And it's fine, I guess,
if that's all you have.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
Shoemaker. I was like,
"I'm not sure about that one."
And Shoemaker was like, "That's
an excellent joke about Pepsi."
That's why -- I guess
that's about it, though.
Like, Pepsi's got
a lower ceiling.
Honda has issued a recall
for more than 300,000 vehicles
due to an issue
with the side view mirrors.
Apparently what happened was all
the objects in the mirror
are exactly as close
as they appear.
[ Laughter ]
A driver in Minnesota reportedly
gave a sheriff's deputy
a get-out-of-jail-free card
from the board game Monopoly
along with his license
during a recent traffic stop.
But it didn't work and he ended
up getting his car towed.
[ Laughter ]
A Great Dane in Virginia
recently gave birth
to 21 puppies
over 27 hours of labor.
Though, when it was
all said and done,
it turned out
she was a Chihuahua.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
A Great Dane in Virginia
recently gave birth
to 21 puppies.
Well, she certainly knows
"roll over."
[ Laughter ]
Scollins.
According to a new study,
Jacksonville, Florida,
has the worst drivers
in the country.
Said drivers, "Let me see that!"
[ Laughter ]
And finally, scientists believe
they've found a new source
of water on the moon,
and Gwyneth Paltrow already
has it up on her site.
And that -- that was
a monologue, everybody.